you
[Music]
so welcome to the first lecture so this
is the closest mathematical foundations
of data signs so the word mathematical
is important because you know data signs
and sort of buzz words like that have
very many meanings right some of them of
course have to do with data but this
course on the face of it will have
something to do with data we will see
some motivations today but after they
will forget data it's a lobby
yes mathematical vectors and vector
spaces and so on but it has connections
to data I will motivate that so the
first part of the first lecture will be
atypical because we are going to give
motivations and sort of connections to
real good things most of the time we'll
move on and just prove things
mathematically right its foundation so
I'm not going to tell you necessarily
particular models of particular
situations occasionally I will give you
examples like I will do now
but generally I want generally it'll be
abstract right there are two aspects one
is algorithms on earth models stochastic
models or deterministic models
algorithms and tools you'll see both of
these this follows a book and I meant to
give the reference but so it's a book
I'm writing with Avram Blum and John
half-off Croft called foundations of
data science and you can download it
from Hopcroft website and what we are
going to do in these lectures or
chapters 2 & 3 I'll stress this as we go
along the prerequisites of course you
are all familiar with linear algebra
multi very calculus probability basic
probability right I will assume that and
I'll stress that ok so with that I'll
move on as I said the first part of the
first lecture is a typical I'll I'm
going to give you motivations
ok so for this course each data point is
in real space D dimensional real space
I'll always use D for dimension where D
is large now you can there are
equivalents
now the reason for this
in fact I'll give you an example in many
modern applications it D is a number of
features each coordinate is a feature
and each data point has one component
for each feature and tells you the
importance or the weight of that feature
right so if you have images there
represent differences and then we'll see
how documents are represented in this
way and now you can say this is not
universal sometimes coordinates or
boolean or some things like that yes
that's true
but most of the time they are real in
this course we'll deal with real vectors
also there's much nicer mathematics to
do with real vectors that I can do
easily understand and other things so
we'll just do that in this course for
now for us then data points or yes
points in Rd there are two things you
can look at one is the modeling part I
mentioned this sort of modeling part
what features should be used what should
be the value of each feature value so
we'll see in a minute example of
representing documents by vectors and
when you represent documents by vectors
each component may be the frequency of a
one particular word component
corresponds to a word and the frequency
may be frequency is not the right thing
you should take the square root of the
frequency of the log these are the kinds
of details we won't worry about here
right but somebody who does the modeling
has to worry about to get a good model
so we assume that it's their job they
have done the modeling and given us
points in Rd right that's that's what
we'll do here and the second part is
understanding and processing data
mathematical structure properties of
data and so on as well as algorithms
right so of course mainly this is the
second part with occasional examples as
I'm going to now describe right at this
point I'm going to describe some
examples of modeling right okay so
example 1 which is a fairly standard
example so if you have a collection of
documents I want to represent them
represent each document as a point in D
space where these large right so let's
say the documents use the vocabulary
D words or terms every word may not make
it to your list of terms
I mean articles may be omitted and him
you know and things like that
this kind of pruning the modular does
you don't worry about it it's given to
us after all the pruning is done and we
represent each document as a D vector D
dimensional vector which lists the
frequency of each term in a document or
it may be the square root of the
frequency or whatever but if some
function of the frequency usually okay I
guess this was supposed to be an example
so here's a random document these words
occur I mean these words occur with very
high frequency right and so you know
what the document is not I mean one
question is right we completely forgot
the context we didn't worry about which
words occur next to each words right so
we don't worry about that is called the
bag of words representation even though
it throws away a lot of information it's
turned out to be quite useful and used
in a lot of applications if you want to
worry about neighboring words you could
worry about pairs of words and their
frequencies pairs of words occurring
next feature
so by grams they call and their
frequency so you could do things like
that those are tweaks to the model but
there's just an example to say documents
or representative vectors one more
example which also is crucial so if you
have a collection of D or L so if you
have if you want to describe the whole
web let's say all the URLs are there d
of them the D is very large right
billions each URL I'm going to say
becomes a D vector with zero one
coordinate right and zero one is one in
position I if there's a hypertext link
so one particular URL I'm looking at has
become a vector and the vector site
component is one if there's a link from
that URL to your URL to the eye to the
oral in the collection zero otherwise
zero one vectors right of course there's
a bit of you don't have to list it this
potentially could be d squared
right but of course most of them are
zero everybody points to I don't know
what most seven URLs on average so this
is very sparse there are only 17 on
zeros you would only list them but this
is the kind of detail we don't worry
about at the moment but there are 70
rather than d squid once tool is right
so I suppose most of this went away so
ok so you may ask
so far I've said take documents or take
your else plunk them down as vectors
that seems actually a trivial exercise
all I have done is made a list of things
I could have made a list or a linked
list or any other data structure so you
can say what point what's the point of
calling them vectors okay that turns out
to be a point it's not obvious
immediately there turns out to be a
point that for instance correlation
between URLs so this is a URL four and
five I want to know how many URLs do
they both point to how many common
pointers are there from these URLs as
you know four zero one vectors that's
just a dot product but dot product of
vectors turns out to be more prevalent
more useful measure of correlations
between data points so one reason for
listing them as vectors is perhaps you
can do things like dot product right
instead of having a linked list or
something so the vector thing is useful
now not only dot products but it turns
out orthogonality and everything is
quite useful angles
let me other quantities orthogonality is
very useful also principal components
which I will define in a minute and will
be covered in the second part of the
course will also turn out to be very
useful in a lot of applications so this
is not just a bookkeeping exercise to
put them down as vectors in sort of
linked lists or stack or something like
that right it's not just a pointless
exercise
so I should I will soon say something
controversial so you can have questions
right now okay
so high dimensional geometry so so far
what happens we have seen that we have
seen that data can be represented
usefully if you believe me and we have
to still demonstrate that in very high
dimensional space in this example DS and
the billions right so it's still
feasible because it's sparse but it's in
the billions so we have seen that so it
will be nice to see what billion
dimensional space
what vectors in billion dimensional
space look like right that will be the
first two weeks of the course of this
mini course right to see some properties
of high dimensional geometry so since
data consists of points in high
dimensional space it's important to
understand properties of high
dimensional space and these are quite
different from two and three dimensions
and that's what I want to communicate in
in these lectures before I go on I want
to say there will be two things that
will hopefully or the highlights of
these two weeks one is called the
Johnson Lyndon Strauss random projection
lemma which I won't define now but
random projection theorem but if you
like you can look it up and the second
highlight will be how many of you know
Chernoff bounds good I mean we will see
them so the second one will be you have
you have things like Chernoff bounds
four zero one random variables so
Bernoulli random variable you can prove
similar results what they are when I
come to it I will tell you in detail but
for right now I just want to pick a
curiosity a little bit and have you look
up things if you want to write Chernoff
bound zero one random variables now I
could instead take sums of Gaussian
random variables
and I could take sums of squares of
gaussians these all come up so what's
meant here is I have x1 through xn which
are iid and X I is normal 0 1 if this
notation is not familiar this is not the
right course for you right I mean all of
this should be very very familiar IDs I
identical independent distributors right
so and in this case you take the sum of
squares and in that case you just take
their sum or you could take some of
exponentially distributed random
variables so the second highlight of
these lectures will be one result from
which you can derive concentration
properties of all of these so these are
all useful and in practice you have
different proofs that the sums of these
things behave or very close to their
expected value right so when you take
the sum of a bunch of random variables
their sum will be close to the expected
value that's again well I'll put up
things you should know central limit
theorem and large number of large
numbers you should know and if not
revise them they tell you that but
usually the proofs are all different so
one thing you might want to think about
it at home is what common thing can
derive all of these and we'll see one
right you'll see it theorem that that
tells us how to derive all these
concentrations so I'm giving you the
highlights partly to tell you what the
course is but partly also so you can go
and revise up brush up your own lineal
different probability right okay so
volumes and surface areas or just two
integrals and so we can work them out in
3d we can also work them out in any
number of dimensions so 3d is multiple
integration three integrals instead
you'll Rd integrals now right now here
are some simple facts right the volume
of a cube of side 1 in D dimensions is
still 1 ok that's good the
this is the cube right so the volume is
one what's the volume of a cube of side
two if so if they scale up each side by
two and three dimensions you scale the
volume by eight right in two dimensions
by four three dimensions by eight and so
on in D dimensions you scale it up by 2
to the D cuz every dimension scales up
by two good thing to remember what about
the D dimensional sphere also the same
if I up the radius by a factor of two I
have the volume by a factor of 2 to the
B these are all follows by integration
so the fact to remember is so you're
going to be integrating to do this so
you have an infinitesimal cube in D this
is three dimensional right and if I
expand each side by a factor of two the
volume goes up I mean I control it but
volume goes up by a factor of eight
right that's all I'm saying so once you
have that once you have this property
for a cube its true for everything else
like a sphere right this follows from
that why is that because in integrate is
getting the volume of this you'd be
integrating maybe I should just tell you
why this maybe in a picture I won't
actually prove this so here's a sphere
of radius two here's a sphere of radius
one I integrated the volume of this by
taking cubes here and corresponding to
each cube there's a cube of side double
the side right so I so I got this bigger
one by goalie going along any every
infinitesimal cone and doubling the side
doubling each point so we'll see the
volume just goes up by a factor of 2 to
the D because it does so for a cube
therefore for everybody
ok so here's a nice picture that I like
to put up a so things don't really look
like this but this is a picture to
remember so here's a cube of side 1
centered at the origin right and in two
dimensions and here is a sphere in two
dimensions it's a circle of radius R
also one right and clearly that encloses
the
square in two dimensions in three
dimensions I mean the cube doesn't quite
look like this but we have drawn it like
this schematically right in three
dimensions it's exactly touching right
right let's see
so this cube of is side one side one so
here you have a half here so you get
three fourths well you should be able to
I'm trying to work out the distance for
the corner so if you have the origin
here half the each side a vector of all
house that this distance is what is one
over four this photography right D
[Music]
root of the dimension over two
I think this is four dimension the
legend is me whether this is
illustration radius one in four this is
four dimensions right in four dimensions
the corners would be exactly on there
everybody with me now I'm just doing
photography when you go to D dimensions
you get root T over T D is big so this
is enormous ly outside the ball right
the corners of the cube of a outside the
unit ball unit sphere of radius one this
distance is root DT that's all I'm
trying to say here the cube is of course
convex so this picture is not correct
you know this it cannot be that the line
is or it's a convex set but it's just
drawn like that because the Centers of
the faces or inside right so the center
of one of the faces the distance half
but the corners of a out so as you go to
lower dimensional faces there they are
very far out again nothing profound so
far so we will okay I'm sorry I should
meant I should stress this the course
will prove these kinds of statements
properly will compute the volume of the
volume of the sphere and things like
that properly but you might want to do
this
at home you certainly want to review a
multivariate calculus right I mean
that's if it's not fresh on your
fingertips please review it also try to
prove that the volume of the d
dimensional sphere goes to zero as B
goes to infinity so instead of multiple
integration with three integrals you
will get DS can you get 10 to my 10
integrals right and if you work out the
volume properly I won't do this I'm
going to do the volume in a different
way if you work out properly you'll get
powers of trigonometric functions right
you have to integrate deep powers of
sine and cosine and you have to use
multiple angle formulas from
trigonometry so to to do the integral
that's a good exercise for absolutely
just to review your catalyst and then
we'll see that so this picture is trying
to indicate that because this big thing
is a cube of side 1 and it's much bigger
in a lot of ways in the sphere the cube
of side 1 is volume 1 this is going to
be much smaller going to 0 will prove
that will prove that differently will
prove that in a nicer way than multiple
integration by relating it to Gaussian
so in fact I want to use that to bring
in gaussians and the connection to
spheres but you should try to prove it
sort of an elementary way so see if you
can do that ok the next two weeks a very
brief intro to basically singular value
decomposition principle component
analysis they go by both these names
I'll tell you what it is right now but
in the last two weeks of the course
we'll see that so sing so many of you
know principal component analysis but
perhaps you've seen it slightly
differently from what I'm going to tell
you now it's the same thing but I'm
going to tell you in a particular way
which perhaps is more is simpler more
Elementary also more to do with data so
the principal components or just
best fit directions of a set of vectors
so I give you the set of vectors that's
your data bunch of vectors bunch of data
points take the best fit line namely the
line the red line I define best fit by
saying I take the sum of squared
perpendicular distances of these vectors
to that line to that infinite line so
here I've drawn the perpendicular things
I don't take just of a vinegar I take
the sum of squares because you all seen
least squares right this is very similar
to least squares except it's not exactly
least squares because Li squeeze there's
vertical distances right so what does
your calculus least squares do so you
have a bunch of points and you fit a
line to it right now typically you take
the vertical distances square them in
some right now I'm telling you to take
the distance perpendicular to the line
so it's slightly different and the
reason for taking sum of squares is it
as many nice mathematical properties
just as in your calculus least squares
if instead I took some of distances
instead of squaring them but I took
these distances that becomes much more
difficult we've learnt in calculus how
to do least squares right because it's a
sum of squares the derivative is linear
and it's very nice so we do that right
for the very same reason or very similar
reason here also taking the sum of space
is very important so in linear algebra
you always take squares write sum of
squares or vector sum of spaces of
distances the squares are important just
like least squares there will be an
algorithm to do this we'll see that but
this is called this is the best fit line
it's called a first principal component
there are other principal components so
the best fit direction
the first thing is v1 is the first
principle component then you take the
best-fit direction v2 perpendicular to V
one let's call the second principle
component right and so on so v3
perpendicular to both of these the
best-fit direction best-fit meaning sum
of squares from R squared distances
right and finding K such directions
gives you the K principal components and
a lot of algorithms do the following we
find the first K principal directions
and project all data to the space
spanned by these so somehow these are
considered the very important directions
right and it turns out in a lot of
applications that's true
again I'm not telling you all the
details to suggest peep into what we'll
do in those lectures okay and then
algorithms do something in the
projection but the idea is to find these
okay so we'll spend the second part
doing that any questions so far I've
been fairly general so presumably this
is just actually as I said an overview
of what's going to happen I'm going to
do one or two detail things today
probably the simplest things and then
we'll finish okay probability in high
dimensional geometry so please review
you are and be current on your basic
probability you should know what random
variables mean variance independence and
so on are you should know the statement
of the central limit theorem you don't
necessarily have to know the proof right
now but it would be nice if you know the
proof but we won't I should know what
the variance covariance matrix is you
should know what a multi general
multivariate Gaussian density is
probability density right not just fear
achill Gaussian but general multivariate
probability density is dimension all of
these if you're not familiar look up
okay so from probability as I said if a
data quantity is average of many
independent quantities it behaves like
they got a but guy like a Gaussian
random variables a simple image era
right
so many analogies between vectors of D
independent random variables and points
from D dimensional space okay so I said
geometry so far and I suddenly brought
in probability I did so because this is
true that there are many analogies
between vectors in a very high
dimensional space and sums of many
random variables okay
and we'll see we'll see one or two of
those analogies
so if okay this is just saying that
Gaussian random variables is a
particular case of that so this is true
for independent Gaussian random
variables will prove also that if you
have a random point from a d-dimensional
hyperspace hyper sphere centered at the
origin then the sum is nearly zero so
I'm going to draw a picture which we
will which will see I'm going to draw
two pictures for you so one is a sphere
in D dimensions if I take this here this
is d most of the mass of it is near the
equator so this is the equator so this
has 1 minus Epsilon so I haven't told
you the width of the annulus was very
small it's going to 0 as P goes to
infinity so I guess anybody who hasn't
seen it if you want to guess how wide
this annulus is that'll be interesting
how wide will it be as a function of D
right if you've seen it shouldn't guess
it anybody wants to guess
another way of saying that is if I pick
a random point from the sphere it's
highly likely to be close to the equator
by the way what is the equator
what is this region this is the region
set of X let's say so that x1 is small
right I mean if the North Pole is when
x1 is 1 then this is the equator I could
have called any axis anything the North
Pole but I'm calling the 1st axis so the
next one is less than or equal to Delta
so how large or how small is Delta so
that I captured quite a lot of the
volume we'll see that
still no gauge random guesses ok it's
good I mean you're not going to be that
brave that's fine
so we'll show this will also show and
the second thing will be easier this is
one the second thing would be another
picture it should be easier so this was
also in D dimensions and in fact most of
the volume will be in this part so this
1 minus 1 minus epsilon also applies to
something very near the boundary right
so most of the volume will be there will
prove this today in this the next time
or maybe both if there's time but I want
you to think about why these are not
contradictory so I'm going to sweating
two things right I'm saying 99% of the
volume is here I'm also saying 99% of
the volume is here so is that make 100
98% or what happens right think about
that we will think about that so
everybody at least got the facts so I
mean I have to tell you the the widths
of these Angeles
yeah oh the second bit second picture is
again a sphere of radius one right and I
take let's say I make this one minus
Delta I use it yet already let me put
Delta prime so I name left with all
points within Delta prime of the
boundary no this is both of them or
d-dimensional which one is ah this this
come in if I draw a flat like that
that'll be D minus 1 dimensional it's
uniform of the entire board okay it's
uniform with the interior as well as
this you know everything it's uniform
over the entire it's uniform the so the
picture I mean to draw is these are all
pictures of X I mean the magnitude of X
less than or equal
we'll so this is generally true for many
almost all the in fact will prove it in
general this is general I'm again will
state this carefully improve that okay
so again review and be current on
probability so we solved okay so this is
this is the equator thing which is the
first picture on top so this is lecture
one so I'm going to lecture two actually
so I've given that this is a very large
audience so you have to figure out for
the first lecture what's the fraction of
people you want to come back right it
could be greater than 1 or less than 1
but this case may be less than 1 so
we'll see go faster after that ok so the
first factor the second fact this thing
is simpler I'll prove this right now
and possibly also at this rate the
second fact right so I will state a
theorem probably but the gist of it is
most of the volume of any high
dimensional object is near the surface
so this picture is more general so I'm
taking a cross-section and a thickness
so it's a full dimensional I so the
equator is d minus 1 dimensional right
so there it's equator is a plane so the
equator is one dimensionless what I'm
taking the slab right I'm taking the set
of X such that X 1 is less than or equal
to Delta naught equal to 0 along yeah
that clear so this is the equate really
greater I'm taking everybody with in
basically every within distance Delta of
it no we will define Delta and Delta
Prime in a minute but still it seems
contradictory that I should be putting
99% of the mass here as well as here ok
so question is why they both through
this will prove both
so the question would be why is it that
they're both true that does imply that
most of the marshals in the intersection
correct
so ninety-eight percent at least right
if 99% is in this and 99% is in this
their intersection must have at least 98
percent yes so that seems also not
intuitive and that this is where our
higher dimensions will differ right
intuitively in three dimensions if I
take a little slab here and the
periphery their intersection is very
small it looks like so that's wrong in D
dimension it should be 98% because of
these two statements so this is the
second thing that's counterintuitive the
cube and the sphere interaction is
perhaps also counterintuitive absolutely
on the value D in Delta so the 99%
depends on D and Delta so those three
things are related right
what percentage is there I'm D and Delta
is a great circle no okay no in three
dimensions the great circle would have
been one dimensional right so I mean to
say equator by equated the
two-dimensional equator I mean if you
cut through that if you cut through that
which you won't do ever so maybe I could
have taken that as the equator if my
North Pole was there right I could have
put the North Pole anywhere I'm
specifying one thing so okay that is a
good question that raises another
contradiction this is swap every equator
right I can put a North Pole anywhere
they all lead to equator and every one
of those symmetric and they are saying
they are all 99% there's even more
worrisome right if things are getting
worse right so at least for the
periphery there's only one periphery
right only one set of points that are
within Delta prime of the boundary but
for the equator there are infinitely
many because any point could have been a
North Pole
so now we now we are saying something
even worse but every one of those is 9%
it's also true all of these are true
this is a volume of a d-dimensional
object so let's see let's go through all
that right so if you have the earth
right
the usual Equator is just a
one-dimensional thing it's a line it's a
line through right but I mean to call
the equator the two dimensional planar
cut as if we cut the hole into two right
so in D dimensions that planar cut that
cut would have been B minus 1
dimensional but now I'm taking a slash
so it's D dimensional what you're saying
is just a line like we usually think of
the equator is d minus 2 dimensional
yeah so it is nice to keep track of the
number of dimensions because for
instance volume scale up by r to the d
in d dimensions but if i want to do the
same thing with about curves it's be
minus 1 so you have to really keep track
of the dimension so most volume near the
surface let's let's prove this is a
simple much simpler than via equator
thing right so so take any object which
is finite nonzero volume in d
dimensional space i want to argue that
if I shrink shrink a by a small epsilon
it shrinks the volume by a lot in in
high dimension right small shrinkage
shrinks the volume a lot that is somehow
intuitively going to say this right if I
take this unit sphere and shrink it just
by a little bit by Delta prime I'm
saying I've lost most of the volume
right my volume is shrunk an enormous
amount right that's what I want to say
so will denote the shrink the object
obtained by shrinking a by epsilon we
would call it 1 minus epsilon times a so
this is a scalar this is a set of
vectors right it's an object in d
dimensional space which is a set of
vectors what this means is I take every
vector and multiply by a scalar 1 minus
epsilon so every coordinate is
multiplied by 1 minus 1 so that's my
shrunk object 1 minus Epsilon
so what's the volume of one minus
epsilon times a in terms of the volume
of a I want to know that right so if we
shrink in the shrink objects in two
dimensions by a factor of two that's by
a factor of half sorry multiplied by a
factor of half then in two dimensions it
would be one-fourth the area would
shrink right in three dimensions
one-eighth and so on and for general B
for general D we again divide space into
infinitesimal cubes to integrate of side
DX and count how many cubes are there in
this and you can just imagine each cube
being shrunk now so maybe another
picture so for the sphere it's clear if
I take every point multiplied by 1 minus
Delta prime the set of points I get is
this so you know if I had a so you have
some object a and I want to take
everybody in multiplied by 1 minus
Epsilon
an interesting picture is when the
origin is somewhere outside the earth
this is the origin right so what am i
doing I'm taking each point X I'm
replacing it with a point 1 minus
epsilon times X which is on the same
line and they take everybody like that
then the picture will become something
like the same thing the origin may be
still outside in fact it'll it will
still be outside right if the origin
didn't belong to the a it will still
belong to this because I've shrunk every
point by one might as well so the volume
of this I would have computed by taking
small infinitesimal cubes I'm doing
these pictures I mean clearly you know
from multivariate calculus all of this
but I want to go over them once at least
so that when we go to D dimensions I
mean D dimensions you can't draw the
picture
at least you can imagine what happens so
you take this and you shrink it by a
factor 1 minus epsilon then it will
become a cube somewhere else it may not
be the original object right if I shrunk
it some of these cubes the shrink thing
will the shunt thing will be outside we
don't get it it's that cube now this
object is made up of cubes like that
it's one to one you have to convince
yourself for their interval to be
correct you have to convince yourself
it's one to one you're not completely
obvious right because the origin is
outside and you're shrinking may go
outside but it's still true that every
cube goes to a shrunken cube and every
strong compute came from one cube again
in 3d you can imagine these pictures but
it's also true in higher dimensions now
if you take any cube and I do there's
one minus epsilon thing it'll still be a
cube even if the origin is not the
center so if that you okay there's a
good point
you know you should convince yourself
that that's true cubes shrink two cubes
okay that's that's important otherwise
all I'm saying is not going to be true
right that's right we maintain or
another way to say it is a cube says
that x1 minus the center is at most one
in absolute value if I shrink it x1
minus the new centers also shock will be
at most one minus Epsilon right so that
you have to prove that cubes for the
cubes for these statements to be true
but they do okay good
so we divide space into infinite is no
cubes and see how many cubes are inside
there's a one to one okay so this is
this is what you're asking one to one
corresponding cubes aside I'm cubes of
side 1 minus epsilon DX contained in
this draw a picture on the board okay so
the the TEC would have cost me a lot of
time to draw so that excited yes okay so
what even the D dimensional cube of side
that is you've shrunk T sides by 1 minus
epsilon factor so you multiply the
volume by a factor 1 minus epsilon to
the D therefore we get a lemma which we
approved now
right because of the integrals that the
volume of one minus epsilon times a is
that most one minus epsilon to the D
times a and here's an important
inequality should remember throughout
the course one minus X is always less
than or equal to Y of X for all real X
there's probably the most used
inequality in this course or any other
course right but it's true for X
negative positive everything always true
therefore this one it gives you this
factor what does this tell you the most
important thing here is D is in the
exponent right so if epsilon is 1 over D
already it starts falling
if epsilon is 10 over D you get e to the
minus 10 right so it's a very small
fraction so this delta prime delta prime
is order 1 over d so in a thousand
dimensions most of the volume is within
one thousandth of the surface 1 over d
so that's the width of the annulus we
will later also want to find the width
of such an you life for gaussians and
for gaussians the width is 1 over root D
it won't be the same so if I pick n
gaussians right and plot them as point
sorry deep V Gaussian plot them as
points in d dimensional space there will
be an annulus but of width 1 over root D
so that most of the probability mass
lies there will prove that but it's
still an annulus so what I'm now saying
is this Delta prime depends on the
object for the sphere it's 1 over root 1
over D the Gaussian should be 1 over
root D for various other objects it'll
be different for cubes also it'll be 1
over D I didn't prove that but that's
something you should
the other way inequality yes so this is
this was exact right this this was the
exactly good point so the volume of 1
minus epsilon times P is exactly equal
to 1
right no loss there only when I went to
you to the minus epsilon DL or something
okay specializing to the sphere we get a
slightly better statement I mean the
statement that we wanted all but II -
the minus epsilon D the volume of the
unit hyper sphere lies within distance
epsilon of the surface why is that
because every point at distance at most
Delta Prime from the surfaces in the
annulus and vice versa the annulus here
consists precisely of the set of points
within distance Delta prime of the
boundary right but just for the sphere
that's true but it's not necessarily
true for everything for the cube if I
shrunk it by a factor of 1 minus epsilon
but I draw only up so you do get a you
do get a square right but this is not
necessary this is not the set of points
at distance at most Epsilon from the
boundary that's it that's it is
different let's say this sort of little
bit rounded
okay so that proves what we want the
volume near the boundary yeah yes I'm
sorry yes I called it epsilon here yeah
it's so if somebody told you that data
points were uniform random from us here
if you have a lot of data points most of
them will have some of space nearly one
right there almost nothing near the
origin there's all of this is empty
space okay there'll be nothing near the
origin it's also true of gaussians we'll
see that if I pick X 1 through X P iid
gaussians there'll be almost no
probability mass near the origin the Sun
will not be nearly 0 most of the time
I'm sorry sum of squares will not be
nearly 0 most of the time some will be
nearly 0 sum of squares won't be
but what about the sphere of radius R no
it just all scales where to the D right
nothing nothing new or interesting ever
so that's that picture I know that's one
over T everything essentially Lots
everything lies there so the tightness
is the difference between 1 minus
epsilon to the D and e to the minus
epsilon T you know this is exact right I
didn't lose anything so it's you know
it's exactly equal to 1 minus epsilon to
the D times the volume of this so if
these are thousand does the power of
thousand if you consider an arbitrary
object what happens okay that's a good
question so for very bad shaped objects
things are not so easy to say so if I
take a cube it'll still be a cube it'll
be reasonably nice right so this is a
side up this is half let's say this this
would be 1/2 times 1 minus epsilon it's
not this corner will be still fairly far
from the corner right the middle of the
face will be epsilon distance but this
is epsilon times Rudy there's always the
root defector coming in right but if you
take a long Kinney object like that and
take 1 minus epsilon of that then
that'll cut off somewhere very far that
and we have to work it out for every
object but for bad shape shaped objects
the volume is still one has epsilon to
the D that's exact but the distance will
be a lot from the corners because only
four cubes and spheres two volumes
behave more or less like distance to the
D power for all shaped objects no so
here the volume is this dimension which
is very small times two other dimensions
which are much bigger so the linear
transformations don't preserve lengths
they preserve volume
there are many examples like the URL
example where the vectors came from a
real-world application which had only
zero one vector right but once we make
them points in these space we forget
combinatorial properties like zero one
and only look upon them as real points
and then we can shrink them expand them
anything so all of that is interesting a
much more striking example of this which
I which is not going to be in this
course where you make vectors which
don't we make points data into vectors
where it doesn't seem to mean anything
is optimization so you all know the
Traveling Salesman problem right where
you have toes through cities and you
want to find the minimum length - if you
don't know it don't worry because
there's not time to explain it but it
turns out the way to solve this the most
common way to solve this problem is to
make each tour into a zero one vector
which tells you which edges you take and
you take those zero one vectors
put them down in that high dimensional
space and you consider the polytope and
you optimize over this poly tope that
turns out to be the best thing one way
of optimizing over polytopes is going
through the interior to the optimal
point these are called interior point
methods in the interior you will have
absolutely non zero one vector right so
even though combinatorially original
problem was only zero one go into real
geometry space without with everything
real vectors turns out we've reuse and
that's so for also the URLs and all
these examples but optimization we won't
see in this course right that's a
completely different context in which
you turn data into vectors and then
forget about data it's just vectors that
you do
okay we have come to the end of the hour